ALEX LESTER: Hello.
Thanks so much for coming, and
welcome to our presentation.
Today, we're going
to talk about how
to achieve data-driven
application growth using
Firebase.
My name's Alex, and I'm
an engineering manager
on Firebase predictions.
YANLI LI: Hello.
I'm Yanli, a software engineer
on Firebase predictions.
ALEX LESTER: So
let's talk about how
Firebase can help you, as
an application developer,
grow a successful business.
We all know that
building a great app
is something important.
But it's only half the battle.
You want to grow your user
base, retain your users,
monetize them, so you
can grow your business.
So today, we're going to
talk about a few key points
in your journey.
Firstly, how can we objectively
measure your application
success, both in terms of
industry standard metrics
and events that are unique
to your application?
Secondly, we'll
be looking at ways
to make changes
to your app's look
and feel, as well as
behavior, without having
to do a release to the
various app stores.
Thirdly, we'll look at ways
to predict user behavior
using machine learning.
And lastly, we'll be able to
test those changes to ensure
that there's been
significant impact
and that the changes
we've made are not
having any unintended effects.
So let's start with a simple
example of an application
that you could
build, and then we'll
adapt it to some more
sophisticated strategies.
So let's consider your new
app, Sparky's Adventure.
In this app, you've decided
to offer in-app purchases
to the user while you
continue to develop features
to make the app more
interesting and appealing
to a wider user base.
As your app develops
and our team
becomes more
sophisticated, we try
to run some tests to help
improve this process,
or to ensure the changes that
your team makes don't undo
any of your previous hard work.
But these tests
can involve a lot
of one-off engineering
time, which ends up
being difficult to scale.
But this is where
Firebase can help.
Powerful Firebase back-ends
like cloud functions,
cloud Firestore,
and cloud storage
allow you to quickly build
and scale your application.
Firebase also has
great tools to make
sure your app stays
performing and crash-free,
with products like Crashlytics,
Test Lab, and Performance
Monitoring.
But Firebase can also provide
you with some out-of-the-box
solutions that can help
you grow your user base,
retain your users,
and monetize them,
so you can maximize
your business success.
So let's say one day Jane,
your product manager,
wants to test the hypothesis
that showing the most
expensive items first will lead
to more users spending more
money per average user session.
Well, that's an
interesting idea.
But it brings with it
a lot of questions.
What other implications
could this change have?
How would we measure success?
Let's start by using Firebase
to get some key indicators
for this app.
First off, we need
to add some analytics
to our app to measure
the success of our app.
Now, the nice thing here
is that you've already
integrated with Firebase.
Analytics is already
up and running.
And if haven't, just by creating
a project in the Firebase
console and adding the base
SDK to your iOS or Android app,
you can get Analytics
up and running
without any custom code.
You get a whole lot
of automatic reports
right there in the
Firebase dashboard on data
that's important to us--
things like in-app
purchases, user engagement,
retention cohorts, daily
and monthly active users,
and more, all of
which lets us get
a good sense of the overall
health of that app right out
of the box.
We will also go ahead and
record any events that
are important to
your application,
whether that's people
finishing a round in your game,
visiting the in-app store,
starting or completing
your in-app tutorial,
inviting a friend, and so on.
This is all data that
we can use later,
either in the Firebase
dashboard or through BigQuery
to answer questions that we
might have about our app,
like, what percentage
of my users
are making it
through the tutorial?
Is level five too hard?
Is level five too easy?
Adding these events
needs generally one line
of code per event.
Back to our original idea.
Now that we know that we can
measure the success metrics
we care about.
But how can we
implement this change
to part of the audience
in a controlled way
and roll back quickly
in case it doesn't work?
How can we make these changes
without an app release?
You can do it using
Firebase Remote
Config as the primary driver
of changes to your app.
Now, if you've never used
Remote Config before,
you can think of it
as like a key value
store that lives in the cloud.
And you can use these values
to change the look and feel
or behavior of your
app without needing
to publish an update to
the various app stores.
The way Remote Config works is
you set up a bunch of values
locally in a user's device.
Then as time goes
on, when you want
to change one of
these values, you
can do that using Remote Config,
either in the Firebase console
or using our REST API.
Then, the next time the
user starts up the app,
we will download these
values and apply them
on top of the default values.
When we ask for a
value, you'll likely
get the default value that
we supplied initially,
or one of the new values we've
downloaded from the cloud.
And this is nice,
because it means
that we can have hundreds of
values wired up and ready to go
through Remote Config.
But because you're only
downloading the deltas--
the values that have changed--
you don't have to worry about
excessive downloads or data
usage every time a
user starts the app.
So for instance, if you've gone
ahead and parameterized a sort
order of the items in the
store as a variable in-app,
this is something we can update
easily through Remote Config.
You can push our
update to the world,
potentially only for a small
fraction of our audience.
And if there's a
problem, you can simply
come back to Remote Config and
undo the change that we made.
OK.
So you have the
change ready to ship.
But wait.
Jane has had a new idea.
Jane is wondering if
you can change the sort
order to show the most expensive
items first, but only do it
for the people who have spent
money in our application
before.
Her hypothesis is that
this will maximize revenue
among your spenders, while
still enticing our non-spenders
to spend money by showing
them more affordable options.
This is something we can do
pretty easily with the systems
that we already have in place.
When you implement
analytics, you
have the ability to
create audiences.
These are users who meet some
set of criteria in your app,
based on triggering events or
being assigned to various user
properties.
And one audience that analytics
creates automatically for you
is purchasers.
This consists of anybody who
has ever spent in your app.
One of the nice features about
Remote Config that I haven't
mentioned yet is
that it contains
logic that allows you
to send different values
to different users,
depending on their situation.
So for instance, you can
send different values
to your Canadian users,
either for a nice localized
experience--
Sparky's Canadian Adventure--
or test a new feature in Canada
before rolling it out to
the rest of the world.
But you can also deliver
a different experiences
based on analytics data,
like whether a user is
in a certain audience.
So you can tell
Remote Config, hey,
let's create a special condition
based on whether or not people
are in the purchasers audience.
And then you can
tell Remote Config
to change your sort order
only for people in this group.
And you get to implement Jane's
new monetization strategy, all
without touching any of
the code in your app.
While this makes Jane happy,
it also gets her thinking.
What if our past purchasers
tend not to spend money again?
Thus we should focus on racking
expensive items more highly
only for future
purchasers, meaning
those that have not
purchased but will likely
purchase in the future.
Can we really
predict the future?
Yes, you can, with a little
help from machine learning.
And we're going to do this by
using Firebase Predictions.
Let me hand it over to
Yanli, who can teach us how.
YANLI LI: Thanks, Alex.
Yes.
With Firebase
Predictions you can
apply the power of machine
learning to segment
you are users based on their
predicted future behaviors.
The general idea is that as
your users are interacting
with your app, the day getting
sent to Google Analytics
for Firebase.
Once enabled,
Firebase Predictions
will look at our data and
learn from the patterns
that your users exhibit before
they perform certain actions.
So let's dig a little
deeper into what we do.
It's actually-- this is a
supervised learning problem.
The first thing is to
come up with examples
to teach a model
what it is exactly
that you want it to learn.
The motto is updated
every day, so every day we
take the last 45 days
of user activity data,
reserve the last 7 days
as the labeling window,
and the past 38 days
as the feature window.
In the labeling
window, we figure out
what actually happened and
give labels to the users,
such as churner, spender,
reviewer, et cetera.
And in the future we
know we [INAUDIBLE]
features that can represent
the user's behavior patterns.
The data is separated into
training set and evaluation
set.
We feed the training set
into a neural network powered
by TensorFlow for
training the model.
Then, we apply the model
to the evaluation set,
to generate statistics about
quality of the predictions,
such as precision, recall,
accuracy, et cetera.
And then we expose some of
these metrics on the UI.
Once the model
quality is verified,
we are ready to apply the
model on our latest user data
to generate prediction
scores [INAUDIBLE]..
There, you can target them
in the Firebase products
that you typically
would use, like
for instance, Remote Config.
So how do you use
Firebase Predictions?
Do you need to go
back to the university
and spend several semesters
taking on neural networks
for learning class?
No.
You just need to click this
button here on the Predictions
console, and that's really it.
At this point, Predictions
will start a model training
and evaluation process for the
two [INAUDIBLE] predictions,
spend and churn.
So by default, we
will predict who
will spend money in
your app, or who is
likely to stop using your app.
But really, Firebase
Predictions can
be set up to predict around
any that you have in your app,
like who's going to
create accounts or share
the app with their friends.
Creating customized
predictions is very simple.
You just need to click the
Create a Prediction box
in the Predictions
console, and then
provide a name so you can
easily find it later and choose
the specific analytics that
you want to predict for.
Then, in a couple
of days, you'll
start to get the predictions
that you can work with.
Let's see.
Now the UI shows
your submit a review
prediction is ready to use.
By clicking this Explore
and use prediction button,
you'll be able to
select a threshold
to control the audience size
and prediction probability.
On this Select
user segment page,
you can expand a graph
of [INAUDIBLE] users.
They are sorted from left
to right in how likely they
are to submit reviews.
The probability score
is on the y-axis.
We can use these blue
sliders to select a segment.
And as we move the sliders, you
will see the bars and the data
change on the right
to give us more
information about
the [INAUDIBLE]
that we are selecting.
After selecting
the segment, you'll
be able to choose where
to use the prediction
with other Firebase tools,
such as Remote Config, In-App
Messaging, and Cloud Messaging.
And that's how easy it is
to use Firebase Predictions.
Now you can leverage
the power of machine
learning in your app.
But Jane's just
thinking, what if I
want to dive deep into my data?
Or combine with my
in-house data source?
Or export it to a
third party system?
Firebase and BigQuery
have you covered.
Many of Firebase tools already
integrate with BigQuery,
including Predictions.
To export your Predictions
data to BigQuery,
just go into your settings
and find BigQuery integration
[INAUDIBLE].
The BigQuery
integrations page allows
you to easily manage all
of your links in one place,
turn them on and off, and
[INAUDIBLE] data set, easy.
After linking your
app, data set will
be created for you are
visible from the BigQuery UI.
From here, you can [INAUDIBLE]
against your raw and sample
data you can also
export or join your data
sets with external data sources
to perform custom analysis.
So going back to Jane's request.
We are going to change that
condition in Remote Config
to now include
users who we think
will spend money in the future.
Let's change a condition to
be based on spend predictions,
then further adjust
the percentile of users
will be included.
For example, only
the top 1% users
who are most likely to
spend in the future.
Hit the Save button, and then
change the sort_order parameter
value in a way
that you think will
generate the most of that
revenue for these users.
Great news.
The new sort order for future
spender is ready to ship.
But Jane starts thinking again.
How can we be sure that this
has the intended outcome?
Even if we saw an
uptick in spending,
how do we know that it
was due to the changes
we just made instead
of some random chance
or some other change
in our app or maybe
a promotion we were
running at the time?
Many apps have a variety
of success criteria.
Let's look at ways
that you can measure
the impact of your
actions accurately,
as well considering any
unintended consequences
of your change.
This is what Firebase
A/B testing is for.
A/B Testing helps make sure that
all organizations in your app
are backed up by actual data
and the statistical analysis.
So let's try to prove
Jane's hypothesis by data
by creating our A/B test.
Let's go ahead and
Create experiment
on the A/B Testing console.
Let's choose to
use Remote Config.
In our case, their
target audience
is going to be users
who are predicted
to spend money in your app.
We can run experiment on,
say, 30% of these users.
Then you can tell
Firebase that you
want to maximize in-app
purchase revenue as our goal.
Note that Firebase
can also check
a number of secondary goals.
This is very useful
for determining
the overall health of your app.
If you made a change that
boosted your in-app purchase
revenue that was so aggressive
that it lowered your user
retention, that would
be important to know.
So you secondary goals
can help you check that.
In the Variants section, you can
add a few different parameters
values here.
You can have up to 70
different variants if you want.
Then you can check back
in a couple of weeks
and see what happens.
This is what a sample
report might look like.
These reports come with a
lot of tables and charts.
But the most important
takeaway is this line here
on top of the page.
It tells us that
for this experiment,
we have 99.9% confidence
that variant A, which
is ranking expensive items
higher for future spenders,
will increase both estimated
[INAUDIBLE] revenue and user
retention.
So this is great we
tested our hypothesis
using experiments and data.
Now, let me hand back
over to Alex to wrap up.
ALEX LESTER: Thanks, Yanli.
It's worth pointing out
that just about everything
we talked about today--
whether it's using Remote Config
to change how your app behaves
in different situations or
changing how your app behaves
against users predicted to
hit some conversion event,
running an A/B test to
improve your purchase revenue,
or perhaps running a
cloud messaging campaign
to tell users about your
next big sale, all of this
can be done by
anyone on your team
directly through the
Firebase console,
as long as you grant
them permission.
So once your engineering
team has done the work
to set up each of these
features, your growth
team, your game
designers, or others
that want to help
you succeed can
run all of these experiments
or marketing campaigns
directly through the
Firebase console,
while your engineering
team can go off and work
on the next big thing.
And your new app's
monetization strategy
gets to go from a very simple,
provide in-app purchases
and keep pushing more
features kind of a strategy,
to a data-driven,
fully-optimized monetization
strategy.
It creates audiences to get
metrics like Google Analytics,
applies different parameter
values to different audiences,
applies different
parameter values
based on predictive behavior,
and maximizes in-app purchase
revenue through A/B Testing.
So I hope you've learned more
today about data-driven app
development.
To sum up-- one, we measure
our overall app health
and set custom measures.
We can use Google
Analytics for Firebase.
Two, to make changes on
device without pushing
a change through
the app store, we
can use Firebase Remote Config.
Third, to predict
user behavior, we
can leverage
Firebase Predictions.
Four, to prove our
success, we can
leverage Firebase A/B testing.
If you're interested in
learning more about anything
we've talked about today or
any other user application
growth-related
questions, we'd love
to hear from you on the Dory.
Thank you.